une tentative d'homicide à talant
mercredi soir deux jeunes ont été prises
à partie l'un d'eux a même été blessé
par balle tout serait parti d'une vidéo
que ces deux jeunes inconnus des
services de police tourné dans le
quartier de la fontaine-d'ouche regarder
les précisions vincent collet bamba
guèye
talent aux alentours de 23 heures
mercredi soir deux jeunes hommes de 18
ans sont rattrapés par leurs
poursuivants l'un est roué de coups
l'autre s'enfuit dans ce parc plusieurs
balles sont tirées cinq douilles de 9 mm
seront retrouvées sur place
j'ai entendu des bruits qui
ressemblaient pour moi et des pétards ça
m'a aussi fait penser à un pistolet
mitrailleur tac tac tac tac tac comme ça
le jeune homme est touché une balle a
traversé son volet c'est ici que les
jeunes qui a été blessé à la jambe a été
retrouvé par les forces de police
nationale ils ont pratiqué un garrot sur
cette jambe et ensuite ils ont appelé
les services du samu qui sont intervenus
très rapidement pouvoir le sauver parce
qu'il était en grande détresse la
victime est désormais hors de danger ce
matin le maire a pu s'entretenir avec
son ami il a peur de sortir il m'a
demandé de pas donner ses coordonnées ce
que bien entendu je m'en suis engagé à
faire et il est
vraiment choqué tout a commencé dans le
quartier dijonnais de la fontaine
d'ouche tout proche selon leurs dires
les deux amis passionnés d'image
urbaines sont allés filmer les bâtiments
de l'avenue du lac leur présence et leur
activité aurait déplu un groupe
d'inconnus la suite la fuite en voiture
des deux talantais bientôt rattrapé par
d'autres véhicules reste à comprendre
les raisons d'une telle violence
ce que j'explique c'est que les photos
ont dû certainement les déranger voilà
et est-ce qu'on peut accepter ça est ce
que c'est un crime de prendre des photos
à 23h à la fontaine d'ouche c'est ça qui
est inadmissible
la police judiciaire a été saisie de
l'enquêté